esteemed members of the global chess
Community dear friends and everyone
around the globe it is with great honor
and excitement that I share with you
today that I was appointed the global
head of the gift of Chess and I accepted
this role with a sense of commitment and
dedication
my name is Susan namangale from the warm
heart of Africa and my life has not been
the same since my sister Gladys
introduced the chess set to me that was
donated to her by Peace Corp volunteer
the gift of Chess is a charitable
organization transforming lives through
our universal language of chess
we distribute chested globally
leveraging chess as a low-cost high
impact Catalyst igniting opportunity and
releasing human potential
our key initiatives include education
prison and Refugee Outreach our goal is
to distribute 1 million chess sets
globally by 2030 by donating 1 000 plus
chest sets to each country globally
what started as an Outreach project to
provide ten thousand chess sets to
students across New York City during the
height of the pandemic is now a global
organization using chess to change the
world
the gift of Chess has currently made a
significant impact reaching several
African countries and the United States
of America and we continue to reach out
to Europe Latin America and Asia through
our ambassadors like abimanshu Mishra
the youngest Grandmaster in chess
history and other volunteers
we are witnessing incredible
life-changing stories of growth and
empowerment like those stories of tunde
and akoya through chess and slums in
Nigeria Tony Ballard in the United
States of America prisons and many
others
today I come to you with great humility
to make a global call for support we
request your assistance as we strive to
expand our reach and impact your
generosity can help us sustain our
program activities across the globe
we are asking 1 000 people globally to
become Builders and make commitments to
supporting us on a monthly basis
you can choose to empower more young
minds by selecting from the available
options so you can choose to build a
Chase set with a 10 monthly donation
you can support the delivery of one
chess set to a deserving individual
fostering opportunity for Learning and
growth
with a 50 monthly donation
you can support the distribution of five
chess sets expanding up access to chess
education and its accompanying benefits
you can choose to build a chess
Community with a hundred and fifty
dollar monthly contribution you can
empower the development of three chess
communities fostering a network of
enthusiasts the Educators and players
who can share their passion and drive
positive change
the gift of Chess is a global community
of Builders building something out of
nothing building opportunities with a
single chess set join us as a builder
together let's make some moves to make
something out of nothing I therefore
invite each and every one of you to join
us in this Noble course let us unite in
our passion for chess and our commitment
to make a positive impact on the lives
of others your support will not only
contribute to the growth of the gift of
Chess but also live a lasting Legacy of
empowerment and transformation
thank you
[Applause]